this video is sponsored by surf shark
this arc
is incredible and if there's one thing
i've learned about this series over my
time reviewing it is that
words are cheap this arc acts as the
climax to well over 500 chapters worth
of buildup and storytelling it provides
breathtaking
action and tragedy on a scale of the
likes of which most stories never even
dream of approaching and while this arc
is
as i said incredible it also serves to
punctuate that not only is this world
far more savage and ruthless than i once
anticipated
not only is the story more morally grey
and tragic than we once perceived but it
also emphasizes that this
modern epic of a tale is still nowhere
near done and that this adventure
whether we are emotionally ready for it
or not
is going to continue i'm totally not
mark and this is my first impressions of
thoughts on and review 4. a tale that
made me cheer
made me smile made me angry and it made
me weep with despair
this is my review for the story that
broke me one piece's greatest
achievement to date
the marine ford
[Music]
this arc opens in a manner that is
uniquely tense achieved by way of not
showing us the main protagonistic group
at all
but by instead deciding to let the world
of one piece act as its very own
character
focusing on showing us collections of
its inhabitants in various circumstances
and locations dropping what they are
doing and shifting their attention to
the screens erected for this specific
occasion
something like this hasn't happened in
one piece to date which serves the scene
incredibly well
impressing unto us the spectacle sense
of occasion and importance
this moment means within the world it's
taking place within with baited breath
thousands if not
millions of people await the moment that
will change everything
a moment that could very well harken in
the end of an era
the execution of fire fist ace
and with that attention grabbing opening
sequence comes one of the most
illuminating revelations this series has
yet unveiled while flanked by the three
admirals and five wards of the sea
fleet admirals sen sengoku announces
that the execution of ace is incredibly
important due
to his parentage his mother was revealed
to be a lady by the name of poor gus de
rouge
who resided in the south blue and his
father none other than the former king
of the pirates
gold d roger this man
this left me utterly stunned last week i
made predictions and drew conclusions
because i thought he was luffy's
biological brother
at the time all i knew about the
character was that he never took the
monkey name and resented his father
therefore i assumed he specifically
didn't want to have anything to do with
dragon and so didn't take the monkey
name
in the same way luffy is told not to
speak about him specifically and so when
it was revealed that goldie roger was in
fact his biological
father i was utterly floored and what's
more is that something of interest
regarding the music design within this
particular episode of the anime during
this reveal
is interesting to say the least during
this specific reveal there's more going
on on a musical technical level than you
might have thought
using a music technique called the light
motif a light motif is a piece of music
that represents a person place or thing
for example think superman's theme or
the forest theme from star wars
some these are recognizable pieces of
music that represent either a person
or an idea and using these light motifs
intelligently during a long-running
series like one piece can offer a bunch
in the way of adding more underlying
meaning to a scene
or in this case with ace foreshadowing
if you listen to this scene before it's
revealed that goldie roger is the father
of ace
we hear roger's theme play meaning had
we been listening for this
it would have been possible to predict
that roger was ace's father simply by
listening to the music
which is a really fun little piece of
musical design trickery i thought
but all of that is honestly small
potatoes compared to what emerges from
the oceans following this
the captains of the new world and
whitebeard make their grand
entrances with whitebeards specifically
emerging from beneath the ocean in a
grand fashion
setting the scene dramatically literally
making luffy and his forces
afterthoughts these massive presences
collectively tell us that the new world
is no joke
and that luffy could very well be out of
his depth
ace's flashback there's a fascinating
sequence of flashbacks that go through
ace's life after he left luffy three
years before his adventure even began
during which he turns down an offer to
become awarder of the sea
and earns the respect of whitebeard from
afar but perhaps the most
interesting piece of information from
this sequence to me
was a single panel of the manga showing
his first encounter with
shanks where a brief but somewhat
interesting conversation takes place
and okay i'm aware i could very well be
digging in a place that has nothing to
glean but
here i go anyway he brings up the fact
that seven years ago shanks saved his
brother
shanks with this single piece of info
immediately knew who he was talking
about saying that he must be talking
about luffy which tells me that shanks
might very well
not be the type of person who makes a
habit of saving people
signifying to me once again that luffy
was specifically special
for some reason that still eludes me a
reason that was enough to give up his
arm for but
maybe i'm reading too much into that
following this there's a surprisingly
fast collection of events shown to us
that led him to where he is today
how he gained a reputation assembled the
crew tried to take down whitebeard only
to have him be accepted into his ranks
showing to us his interactions with
blackbeard whom he was ranked higher
then
it's a super interesting story but
something that really stuck out to me
and struck me as interesting
was how whitebeard insists that he
ordered ace to do what he did instead of
ace having gone off and done it on his
own accord and trust me to say that this
arc has yet to show its hand is the
understatement of the century
not only is the best still to come but
what makes this arc one of the most
spectacularly written sequences
is yet to be shown this is a war
both thematically narratively and
visually with the inclusions of
characters like whitebeard making
massive moves unveiling to us this
incredible devil fruit power
the ability to create earthquakes on an
ocean battlefield this can create
tsunamis and on land this can level an
entire civilization it's the single most
destructive and impressive power that's
been revealed in this series to date
which in and of itself is already full
of tremendous incredible powers
and that's not to say that we don't get
introduced to other spectacular powers
in this thick boy of an arc either one
of the main men working under whitebeard
goes by the name of marco and his power
is incredibly cool maybe even
overpowered
as he wields the strength and ability of
a phoenix which
on its own is nuts additionally we
finally get to see more from don
flamingo who to me has
all the charisma and chaotic neutral
attitude of deadpool on a number of
occasions we see him laughing at both
the misfortune and fortune of the navy
and the pirates respectively wanting
only for things to get more interesting
demonstrating no particular allegiance
other than the side that offers the most
interesting outcome for him to enjoy
which honestly makes for a really
intensely interesting wild card with
some truly curious devil fruit abilities
offering him control of other
individuals it's
really awesome ending on his thoughts
with this quote that i think perfectly
sums up his character's nihilistic view
of the world succinctly
justice will prevail of course it will
because the sign of justice
will be whichever side wins the war
as i mentioned earlier this is a war
that offers a super interesting power
struggle between the navy
and whitebeard's forces acting as a
complex game of chess
where once thought to be loyal pieces
begin acting on behalf of the other side
or in their own best interests
characters like hancock and garf find
themselves either actively taking action
against the navy or sitting out of this
battle entirely as they have too much
emotionally invested in it and it's
through these really complex motivations
and characters we once
again see one piece's greatest strength
rear its head either through giant
struggles with the child of oars
or with the cunning manipulation on
behalf of whitebeard who gets a
tremendous level of shine and
performance in these chapters
highlighting that one piece is a beast
into and of itself with regards his
ability to develop its world
develop its characters and place them
into the most interesting situations
possible but perhaps the most impressive
aspect in this first bit of the arc
is the sheer lack of any main characters
present neither the straw hats nor luffy
are seen very much at all for prolonged
stints of time
instead large portions of time are set
aside for characters like ace
and whitebeard who up until now haven't
received much screen time
at all thus far and this is awesome
because oda knows that we are invested
in the story one way or the other and so
he can present the story in whatever way
he sees fit as the best option without
being burdened by the obligation to
always have luffy or the rest of the
cast present at all times now that's
quality that's confident writing and i
love to see it
but as i was saying this arc's opening
sequence is first and foremost there to
serve two characters with pretty much
every interaction working on behalf of
both of these individuals
including every flashback sequence
building our understanding of the inner
workings with these two but by far the
most insightful being
how whitebeard demands to take full
responsibility for ace's pursuit of
blackbeard
despite it being ace's stubborn idea
with whitebeard
actively advising him against it
recontextualizing ace and whitebeard's
father-son relationship with a
single scene however once luffy does
eventually enter the equation he does so
in
typical loofy fashion falling out of the
sky with a bang
crashing to the sea below immediately
inserting himself into the effort to
save ace while also asserting his
presence
to one of the emperors of the sea in
whitebeard who
really just likes his spirit which on
its own is such an
awesome little scene in it there's a
beautiful sense of progression and loss
while luffy is asserting his
determination to become the king of the
pirates
all the while his crew is nowhere to be
found it's bittersweet to be sure
resulting however in a great snapshot
and opportunity once again for
whitebeard's character to demonstrate
his strategic prowess
taking a warning from luffy citing that
ace was going to be executed ahead of
schedule
and understanding it as a ploy on behalf
of the navy
to try and confuse them which he sees
through and totally takes advantage of
later by the way
this arc made me love whitebeard if i
didn't make that perfectly clear already
when i first saw him i didn't really see
much beyond a man that looks sort of
sickly with stubborn ways and maybe a
drinking problem but
in this arc he is shown to be a strong
man both of body
mind and character one that takes the
first step forward and looks out for all
of his crew as he does so
and it's not just whitebeard we get
acquainted with either a lot of his crew
including characters like marco that i
strictly like because of his awesome
firepowers
i might have a thing for firepowers
pushing that to the side however we also
have a fantastic set-piece sequence
wherein luffy screams to his brother and
their eyes meet
luffy asserts that he will save him all
the while ace laments over luffy being
there in the first place
blaming himself completely as luffy
struggles across the battletorn area
another curious tidbit of passing
information came in the form of the
real bartholomew kuma having now died
and why this is interesting requires me
to go over something i never touched on
last week which was that eva's decision
to help luffy in that rescue for his
brother
came about specifically because he was a
revolutionist part of the forces
of dragon to him he was saving the son
of dragon someone he was sworn to
which on its own adds even more depth to
the situation
but in this instance now in marineford
it becomes more interesting when we
discover that kuma
was a part of that very revolutionary
army under dragon
which places him in the same spot eva
was in which now
makes me understand why luffy and all
his friends survived in the archipelago
all those chapters ago i love this story
and by the way i'm sorry if this feels
like i'm darting from cool moment to
cool moment but this
really is how the first 10 chapters of
this arc unfold
from buggy to croc fighting doflamingo
to luffy finally taking on hawkeye and
that last one was super interesting
primarily because of what hawkeye says
right before he attacks him
i'm gonna leave that on screen for a few
seconds and while the fight itself i
found sufficiently interesting
if not for any other reason other than
it's hawkeye vs luffy but it also
contains some dialogue that feels like
hawkeye is writing a character study on
luffy himself with this line
it's not his powers or techniques he
possesses some quality that makes others
want to help him
and in these waters that is the most
formidable power of all
which is so true but it's also before he
knows the full extent of how special
luffy really is
but more on that later if things already
didn't feel like there was a tremendous
sense of occasion then the next sequence
of scenes will fix that most
definitely the pacing in this arc only
knows one direction and that's up up
up the stakes the consequences and
everything becomes more and more intense
chapter by chapter and this one is no
different
when sengoku orders all the video
transmission snails
to be cut off and that's when this
happens
everyone reading this story at this
point knows how formidable these thick
boys are and so when we are shown an
army of them pressing forward the
feeling of dread becomes
all the more apparent the design of kuma
for a role specifically like this works
insanely well these cold-blooded bots
are very much
terminators both from an action
standpoint and a character design
standpoint
expressionless without even the ability
to see the eyes of the character these
mechanical monstrosities march forward
with the same emotionless malice any
machine would
and because of that their army feels
like all the more like a force of nature
but that's not where things end whoa no
the position they're pressing forward
from
and the timing of their unveiling comes
as a result of sengoku's strategy
while watching this arc unfold as well
as impulse down i was constantly
struggling to justify in my own head why
the navy wanted to execute ace as much
as they did publicly and this sequence
sheds light on that very situation
knowing that someone with the lineage of
ace would draw the ocean's most powerful
and dangerous enemies to the navy
offering what many people would perceive
as only a negative but send goku
in a stroke of strategic genius saw the
opportunity this situation uniquely
presented that no one else saw having
created a field of ice for the battle to
take place on
having now gathered all the pirates in
one area sengoku effectively hatched the
plan to eliminate all the pirates of the
new world in one fell
swoop using the kumas as a means of
eliminating their only escape route
if a lot of people love each other the
world would be a better place to live
but as i was saying there's this
intensely interesting game of chess
taking place between white
what okay stop listen this isn't okay
i was just starting to love whitebeard
as a character and this guy seemingly
out of nowhere
stabs him what gives one aspect that has
been hammered home since the beginning
of this battle and through aces
flashbacks has been the treasured
relationship and bond everyone in
whitebeard's crew
feels with him assuming very much a
father-like role within all of their
lives
with ace being a textbook example of
someone who resented his biological
father only to be accepted and adopted
by whitebeard
who has relationships much the same as
these with almost all of his crewmates
and if there was one aspect of
whitebeard's character that was stronger
than his strategic ability
it would be his love and bond with his
adopted children
though this proved to be an ingenious
attack made by a kainu who fed squad
alive that whitebeard sold out his
children to save ace leading to a
successful attack on him inflicting on
the giant smiling tenacious pirate
his very first wound of the battle and
if you at this point didn't already
love whitebeard he immediately forgives
squad before
embracing him and this just brought me
to tears
it's a beautiful scene that's equal
parts both loving and tragic
knowing how horrible squad must have
felt for having done this to his father
figure the writing for whitebeard in
this arc has been carried out with such
purpose and care
that he honestly feels like the most
realistic dad character i've ever read
about
so much of this man screams wisdom love
and hard work
and i sincerely admire him as a
character for it in the space of
15 short chapters oda achieves this
ludicrously effective father character
that
up until this point i didn't really know
much about and it's feats like this i
just pointed out more so than the cool
battle sequences or epic one-liners
that makes oda for me the best mangaka
of the modern era by far and away
that i've read the work of he's honestly
got a gift and he's not done with us for
this arc either
not by a long shot because the best
stuff is still to come
the final struggle and this is where
stuff gets
really really good without belaboring
the notion that this is the single
greatest war effort i've ever seen
committed to the page of a manga
i want to make it known that the driving
force behind what makes this so
incredibly effective is how well it
implements goals for the audience and
mixes those goals with interesting set
pieces and character matchups
the likes of which we haven't ever seen
before in this series
with callbacks to prior relationships
and techniques creating so many
wonderful subversions
this arc is without a doubt the result
of an exceptionally well told prelude we
all know these characters we all know
their powers
and we understand all the motivating
factors
this is the icing on top of this
magnificent one-piece cake
and man is it sweet this is the moment
the navy showed their true plan however
erecting a circular blockade of steel
walls around the pirates as they
continue to get attacked from the rear
by the advancing army of kuma clones
things are quite literally at their
worst the forces of the pirates are
dwindling and in severe trouble
ace is being ready for execution and
whitebeard
is down
this absolute mad lad what a terrific
character moment for croc firmly
declaring his position in the war effort
screaming at whitebeard to be the
emperor he proclaimed to be and to not
be defeated by such a weak attack
encouraging him to once again regain his
footing and leave the charge in the war
and once again like the monster he is
whitebeard presses the assault ordering
his forces to advance alongside luffy
and his crew with even oars jr who
became injured earlier in the
confrontation
to help lower one of the walls in order
for them to escape however despite
all of this tenacious energy and effort
being exerted by the new world's forces
and
luffy the young pirate recognizes that
he won't be able to make it in time at
this rate
he needs a plan to get closer and
through sheer
genius they utilize the technique that
was established in the prior arc
shooting and erupting from the
battlefield far below lands luffy
right before the three admirals of the
navy unflinching he readies to attack
and push past
anyone he needs to in order to save his
brother
at this time whitebeard's forces managed
to push past the gap created by the
mortally wounded child of oars
and the battle that ensues between luffy
and the admirals highlights once again
how utterly unprepared he is to be in
this situation
possessing within him more heart than
perhaps anyone in this battle combined
despite having tremendous intentions he
isn't able to do this without the help
of
everyone's combined effort and unable to
get past the forces of these exemplary
warriors representing the navy all luffy
can do is watch as sengoku gives the
order and
ace accepts his fate to be executed
[Applause]
i'm sorry is it a hot take for me to say
that croc
is the mvp of this war because he
totally is
it's incredible and i love it it's like
watching frieza fight with goku to save
vegeta but again if not for the efforts
of croc at this last minute and the
eventual reinforcements whitebeard and
his crew offer
luffy would have most definitely been
taken out there and then
and to be honest even with their help he
pretty much
was with whitebeard there and then
trying to bench him
but you do not bench monkey d luffy
which is something whitebeard can't help
but once again
admire about him immediately
[Music]
i did say thanks to surfsharkvpn for
sponsoring today's video now more than
ever our internet reliance has been
rapidly increasing from streaming our
favorite online shows to
heck even a lot of our banking is done
online nowadays we'd like to think our
information is safe but as our online
footprint increases so does our need to
be properly secured surfshark is a vpn
service that protects your information
from unwanted individuals by encrypting
all of the data that you send through
the internet additionally vpns are
important because content from streaming
services can be restricted based on what
country you're in but with surfshark you
can solve that problem by simply
changing your location
not only is this good for people who
want to keep up with your favorite shows
but it's specifically great for me
because i want to watch one piece on
netflix but it's blocked in my country
but not
anymore this very moment surfsharkvpn
has a great deal going by following my
link in the description and using your
promo code tnm it not only gives you a
whopping 85
off but also three months of service
totally for free
surf shark also offers a 30 day money
back guarantee so there's no risk in
trying it out for yourself
now back to the video
during this lot of the action marco
tries to make a move for ace while the
admirals are distracted and the other
forces are preoccupied and this is when
we see some of the most visceral
emotional conflicts from the ark
garp stands in the way of them rescuing
ace the boy he raised
on his face you can see it the
conflicted expression of someone who
doesn't have conviction in the actions
he's taking anymore
right wrong family duty swirling around
his head forming a cocktail of doubt the
likes i've never seen before in one
piece which was a super interesting
dynamic to shine a light on and as
marco's phoenix crashes to the floor
below
the situation worsens whitebeard is
gravely wounded and more than that
is in an incredibly compromising
situation marco was ineffective the
admirals are all dominating their
respective adversaries
and what's more luffy's adrenaline boost
given to him by eva
is no longer sufficient to overcome the
fatigue and injury his body has
sustained over the last few arcs
and because of that he asks him to once
again use his power to give him the
strength the
energy to lift his lifeless body to do
what he believes
needs to be done and the back and forth
here once again encapsulates luffy as
the hero of the story in a way that is
so true to his character throughout this
entire saga
luffy has been losing failing to save
the people he wanted to save
losing his entire crew while he himself
was completely helpless to make the
smallest difference
it's for that specific reason he was
relieved when hancock offered him the
option to save the three women in amazon
lily luffy
absolutely will always choose to save
his friends at great cost to himself
and this instance is no different
knowing full wealth the second
sudden surge of adrenaline into his body
could kill him he demands
and orders eva to do it anyway citing
that he couldn't live with himself if he
didn't do
everything he could possibly to save ace
and with that
his wish is granted and his body becomes
overcome with power and purpose
luffy explodes to his feet and surges
with unbelievable speed towards ace
dodging any and every obstacle that
stands in his way including his friend
kobe
who be without hesitation knocks to the
floor however despite this incredible
surge of raw emotion and strength from
luffy he still won't make it
and once again ace prepares himself for
execution
this made me cry this utterly beautiful
moment a snapshot in time
for two reasons made me cry the sheer
build up an explosion of action that
left me in awe but
also because thematically it works just
perfectly there i go using that word
again luffy's literal love for his
brother
manifests within him and brings out this
hidden power he isn't aware of
in order to save ace his brother from
the clutches of those who would do him
harm
i love this series i don't know how else
to say it it's impossibly good
yet here it is and this moment is it the
singular pause in time the chance they
need to turn the tide in this
war to save whom they came to save as
whitebeard bellows
back up luffy the straw hat with
everything you've got and with the
combined efforts of all the warlords on
their side
including croc all the subordinates of
whitebeard and himself included
eva and even the sudden assistance from
innozuma it takes every
last person giving it their absolute
unmitigated all
to give luffy a single second's worth of
chance
to get into position but once again
someone stands in the way of saving ace
[Music]
the emotions on display are so much more
complicated and rich than i
ever expected them to be having only
been introduced to garp after any lobby
properly his role within the story has
been limited but the light this saga has
shone on him and his character has made
him
especially in this instance an
incredibly touching and moving character
one that has dedicated his entire life
to the line of duty and now when faced
by ace and luffy at the same time
he moves to stop the young pirate whom
he raised but in a moment of pure love
for his grandson he can't bring himself
to do what he's been trained and
conditioned to do
all of his life in this moment we watch
an old grizzled man break
and it's soul destroying but there's no
time to waste and this story doesn't
give me a second to breathe as when
luffy moves with the key to uncough his
brother ace
kizaru out of nowhere in the middle of
his clash with whitebeard
shoots the key to pieces now what
i'll tell you what oda is a butterfied
literary genius and i'll fight
anyone who disagrees with me he utilizes
mr three to create a shield from the
incoming sengoku and creates a wax key
now falling to the ground below the
gallows collapsing under the stress of
the battle we experience the single most
cathartic sequence i've ever in my life
read through
[Music]
when i saw that beautiful fireboy
explode from those cuffs and
land alongside his brother luffy i
honestly felt something akin to a panic
attack fueled by pure joy
if i was to look up the word awesome in
the dictionary i'd find some dumb
definition that has
scientific backing but in reality all we
need is this
image this fight man while brief gave me
everything i needed and more
we get the banter back and forth between
luffy and his brother we get to soak in
ace's fiery greatness as he poses up a
storm we get to see two of them
experience battle together and do
combination moves together
these two do more in this fight than
pretty much any team-up has done in this
series to this date or that i can think
of
and man do i love every single radiating
second
of it to say that i was giddy at this
point would be inaccurate i was at the
time of reading this
irresponsibly happy as they annoyed
pretty much everyone around me
while going through it but as is the
case with all good things
eventually they have to come to an end
stopping in its tracks the very ship
that they need to escape on
with his bare hands stands the mortally
wounded
[Music]
whitebeard
but all is never that simple an admiral
magma
starts blustering insult after insult
towards whitebeard that ace
takes specific issue with and the very
same thing that led him to being
captured his inability to let something
go
causes him to get burned by the admiral
something neither he
nor us thought was possible you'd be
forgiven for believing that this was a
story with a lighthearted conclusion
one that has been earned and built up to
effectively with a tremendous climax
and it has but this isn't one of those
stories
this arc and really this entire saga is
about failure we experienced it at the
beginning during the climax at the
archipelago we observe a new goal in
saving luffy's brother ace against
impossible odds
we watch as luffy through sheer will and
determination and a kind heart
bends the world around him for the
better in order to save his brother's
life
but just as suddenly as he was freed
he's torn away from the young pirate
never to be by his side again killed
in this arc we observe the worst moment
of luffy's
life and it's painted right across his
face
this hits so powerfully because of a
narrative technique incorporating
contrast and anticipation for a scene
like this to glean an emotional response
from its
audience be it negative or positive it
needs to take its viewer or reader from
one mindset into another contrasting one
quickly for example in the case of
makoto shinkai's your name
there are plenty of moments where i
cried with happiness as we go from
moments where we think hope is all lost
to shocking revelations of success
we anticipate something bad to happen
and it's then we get shocked when
presented suddenly
with the opposite our minds are
surprised by what it's seeing and
therefore the perfect setting is created
for an emotional response
but in one piece something i've been
meaning to talk about for quite some
time but never found the perfect place
to discuss it has been how death or
the lack of death is dealt with in the
series this was something i've noticed
all the way through the series but it
became an issue for me first and
foremost
in enduring the alabasta arc where usopp
had his skull
literally crushed by a super heavy
baseball bat this
bothered me because in theory if he was
just a regular person similar to the way
we are on earth
he'd be dead like super dead but
obviously because this is fiction oda
can do what he likes
he can create all of these characters
and make them all super durable if he so
chooses
and they absolutely are recovering from
what would and should be certain death
in a matter of days
this however for me presented another
issue so we have these characters that
are ridiculously durable and that's
totally fine
and they can heal like slow wolverines
cool
that's totally cool but one problem that
this presents is that the viewers and
readers now don't have a fundamental
understanding of what
can hurt or should kill these
individuals and so when i see oda
literally shattering usop's skull
and for him to shake it off in a couple
of days i am then not worried at all
about usopp during the vast majority of
indy's lobby because
i know oda will be consistent and for
the bulk of one piece oda has almost
gone to tremendous effort not to kill
people they are either knocked out or
run away which again is totally fine
although in moments like alabaster or in
his lobby with the various enemies and
side characters it had
i thought death would have been
appropriate for certain instances and
felt like the story was sort of lacking
something in that specific regard but
then we get this moment
i love this scene not necessarily
because i felt the loss of ace
personally
but because i knew that this is the
worst moment
of luffy's life and that shift you felt
there for me pointing out something
negative about the story to suddenly
praising it
is that very technique but in miniature
and much less effective
it's about contrast and shifting values
as i've been saying throughout this
video
this arc has taken a specific focus in
helping us understand
the backstory of ace which in the series
has established a passion of presenting
flashbacks as being an indicating factor
that we either
can expect to see more of this
particular character or to see him join
the crew entirely but more specifically
that they definitely won't
die they'll get hurt but they can't die
and so when ace is freed and fighting in
glorious fashion alongside his little
brother
we go from a poetic euphoria full of
hope with death being impossible to a
sudden stark
wave of reality hitting us as we adjust
to the impossible suddenly being
very possible happy to sad
magic to reality the death of whitebeard
i think whitebeard in this series
represents a presence but more
so an idea he's a story a way of taking
on the world while keeping a strong
sense of togetherness and family at the
forefront of our minds
at the beginning of each book he's
featured in the description of him
is that of the strongest pirate in the
world and as this arc comes to a close
the presence he imposes and the ideas he
represents
dies his era is now over and what's to
follow i can only imagine is much colder
and
infinitely more dangerous what's strange
also is that had the story of one piece
been about
whitebeard it would have been a story
where the real treasure was the family
and friends you make along the way
and that's just who whitebeard is which
i think is honestly sort of beautiful
a monstrous imposing man that despite
being taken to the brink of death and
losing half of his
face refuses to act for himself but for
the lives of his children
his crew and his family also a small but
noticeable recurring motif
i recognized in this section that i
meant to draw attention to in my ini's
lobby review
were these text fields that are dotted
all around
the story of one piece they read like
the writings of a textbook or that of a
storyteller speaking about the time that
has long since passed
in this particular instance it reads
even in death
even with half his face gone he would
never fall
he will forever be remembered as a
monster for the way he destroyed his
enemies that day
in this one battle alone he suffered 267
sword wounds
was struck by 152 bullets and 46
cannon blasts and yet neither that
mighty body
nor his pirate spirit suffered even one
coward's wound to me this says that the
story of one piece is being recalled or
told
so in other words we are hearing perhaps
a retelling of this story
and that also possibly all we've
experienced is essentially a flashback
telling the story of luffy's life this
obviously hasn't been confirmed or maybe
it has i don't know
and i could very well be wrong but right
now it's certainly felt that way to me
climaxing on a quote that echoed
throughout the pages of the manga in
equal parts hopeful and epic
as whitebeard exclaims in his dying
breath the one piece
exists signifying the end of an era
and the beginning of a new one and these
two deaths
ace and whitebeard serve as a massive
loss in the story due to their
significance to the two cornerstones of
one piece the death of whitebeard is a
massive loss to the world of one piece
and the loss of ace is a massive loss to
the main character of one piece
both hold enormous significance and
importance within the wider story and
what consequences there'll be
thereafter and speaking of consequences
there's a surprisingly really
interesting symmetry between blackbeard
and luffy that becomes abundantly
obvious in this arc
specifically both having come from
relatively humble beginnings with a
singular focus to follow their dreams
with reckless abandon and understanding
the full scope of what blackbeard hopes
to achieve in this arc rocks the very
foundations of the one piece story to
its core
hijacking the scene immediately and
unloading a barrage of bullets onto
whitebeard
leading to his ultimate death but
perhaps the most significant aspect of
what blackbeard does in this arc
is this
for the very first time in one piece's
entire story and maybe even its history
blackbeard has become the wielder of two
very powerful devil fruit abilities
with this being sort of unprecedented
territory i wonder if he's even less
susceptible to water right now
maybe not but regardless this acts as an
incredible seed to be planted that sets
the stage for the future of this
world but following these events even
more people begin getting slaughtered it
seems in addition to stealing the powers
of whitebeard blackbeard also convinced
some of the worst
most dangerous pirates from impel down
to join his crew
this is when we get a glimpse of
something we haven't seen since skypia
kobe
starts freaking out that all the people
around him are fading away
they're dying he seems to have this
ability to sense where people are and
what's happening to them
things are in an awful way luffy is
totally out of it having been lifted
away to safety
on trafalgar's submarine even dropping
his hat in the process
and the forces of the pirates are pretty
much spent here also and right as kobe
was about to be taken out
having started his journey as a small
kid with more dreams than he had since
luffy threw out one piece has grown
stronger taken down obstacles built a
reputation for himself
and made countless friends over his
adventures but beyond anything i've
mentioned in this video
what this arc managed to achieve more
effectively than perhaps
anything else has been that feeling that
the more things
change the more they stay the same
with the first chapter story being that
of shanks showing up at the last minute
to make the save for a very young luffy
and in this latest installment rounding
out hundreds of chapters worth of growth
he still needs to save the young
headstrong kid with more dreams than he
has since
even managing to perform the same
gesture by giving him his hat yet again
because luffy isn't ready the war-torn
battlefield bloodied by the bodies of
those that had fought bravely that day
can now rest in peace as shank declares
that the war
is over i do not have words to describe
how perfectly structured and paced this
war was
from the beginning to the end everything
made sense or provided further incentive
to carry on the story
and so let's do that
[Music]
we lag luffy
foreign
the post-war arc for anyone watching my
reviews that have not experienced the
story of one piece first hand i can't
recommend this series enough and no
matter how flowery my language or
how well i describe events that take
place it's not a replacement and won't
compare to the vibrant and rich world
oda's created and that's not even
touching on the magnificent character
and story writing that fills the pages
of jump's biggest seller but for those
among you that prefer to live
through my experiences i'd like to take
this opportunity to apologize in advance
for how utterly ridiculous
this upcoming cliffhanger is going to be
to describe briefly what takes place
within the parameters of this short
post-war arc
all i need to say are three separate
words perspective
training and future kicking things off
we pick right back
up after the events of the prior arc in
a similar fashion to how they kicked off
the last one with the focus fix in the
various communities and gatherings of
people who have been watching it on
large screens around the world
as well as some notable figures in the
pirate community there's plenty of
celebration and there's some speculation
as to what this could mean for the
future among
everyone except one
a substantial portion of this arc is
spent exploring the past of luffy
specifically his childhood as he meets
with ace for the very first time
answering questions i had about how and
why shanks had never met the kid before
garp had left ace you see in a foster
care and we find this out as he leaves
luffy there to get stronger with him
immediately luffy gravitates to ace
despite his insistence on being left
alone and wanting nothing to do with him
day after day the seven-year-old luffy
would try to follow ace who was then 10
years old to play
but day after day despite making it
farther and farther into the forest each
time that ace would escape into
luffy loses him until one day he follows
him the entire way through
the dynamic on show here through this
interaction with ace not wanting to be
around anyone due to his own childhood
coupled with a less refined more
childish version of adult luffy's
personality there's a raw
honest childishness to these
interactions that are dotted throughout
in this story also ace has a friend of
the same age called sabo
and both of them have been gathering
treasures so that one day they both can
become
pirates luffy expresses his desire to
become the king of the pirates someday
but the bond between luffy and ace
doesn't begin establishing itself until
a particular scene where luffy despite
being cornered by a pirate looking for
the loot
a stole luffy refuses to snitch on ace
and it's after this beating oda presents
me with the single most heart-wrenching
image i've ever seen in one piece
in that moment luffy gains the
respective ace but moreover convinces
him that he genuinely wants to be
with him ace has grown up with people
hating him for existing
and luffy in this scene because of who
he is specifically loves ace
because he exists which is just a
beautiful and tragic sentiment that adds
even more perspective to ace's last
words
causing me to retroactively lament and
cry over that scene even more than i
already have
on this adventure ace luffy and sabo
make a brotherly bond
certain that they will all sail the seas
one day to become great pirates
but when sabo's aristocratic past
catches up with him and his father
forces him away from ace
and ultimately into running away from
home his boat is shot by a celestial
dragon
killing him once this is found out luffy
and ace's bond strengthens
as we watch them grow into themselves
together with ace declaring that he'll
never die and that he will always look
after his little brother we get to see
both ace and luffy set sail for the very
first time now with
full context for these voyages and even
though this wasn't particularly sad
i found myself welling up as i watched
luffy set sail again from his home in
the east
blue it's sort of overwhelming to think
about where this kid came from what his
values are and why he has them
forcing me in that moment to
recontextualize everything the series
has shown me up until that point
this little story adds so much color to
an already
vibrant tapestry of a world oda has
already created
creating and reinforcing what could be
now my favorite character in
all of fiction luffy there's so much to
adore about this character but the main
focus of this story without getting too
much into things is how both ace and
luffy need to grow stronger to achieve
their goals
to protect those they love and by the
time the flashback ends both ace and
luffy significantly have grown
incredibly strong and you can see this
on their faces of how sure they are as
they each shove off for their respective
voyages
we've seen their training the
decade-long endeavor luffy has been on
to master his abilities too but as
luffy's modest craft launches from his
humble beginnings into what we now know
becomes a
massive adventure we cut back to the
grim reality he finds himself in
[Music]
hawaii if that isn't heartbreaking i
don't know what is
highlighting quite effectively the stark
contrast for us between the luffy that
left that day and the luffy that lies
both
physically and emotionally broken before
us now still
beating himself up jimbei finally
intervenes
stopping him from doing more harm to
himself luffy throughout this
interaction doesn't even resemble the
same upbeat person who would look
unflinchingly into the future with
optimism he's full of anger resentment
towards himself for not being enough on
top of grieving the single greatest loss
of his life
these are new feelings for him and it
looks like he's about to lose himself in
them until
jinbei points out that he has something
important to live for
that he isn't alone with that luffy
silently counts his fingers
each one representing someone that
depends on him that loves him
and that he loves too
and with that a new energy riles up in
the young bruised pirate as he exclaims
this dealing with loss and reconciling
it into a healthy outlook
is not only a terrific story to read but
also an important one for anyone dealing
with loss and grief
which at some point will happen to all
of us but this
is where the story starts to get
interesting even more interesting than
it already has been
planting more seeds than i can count
forming a massive swerve the likes of
which left me in the single biggest
cliffhanger
of my life really surprises everyone by
swimming up to the island of women that
luffy is currently on
and presents the straw hat with a
proposition the scene then cuts
and we don't know what his plan was it's
at this point we see the straw hats in
individual scenes scattered across the
world
usopp got really fat all in very
different circumstances but all with the
same goal of reconvening with their
captain whom they know
must be hurting incredibly at this
moment like the rest of the world
they've been aware of what's been
happening with regards to the war and
they know what happened to ace
but as they are making their individual
arrangements to head towards their
agreed-upon rally point in the
archipelago
something comes to their attention it
appears luffy
has returned to the spotlight once again
the respective places these straw hats
have found themselves
in have been really interesting too
usops in a giant plant floating in the
ocean choppers in a rather advanced
civilization although their appearance
might be a little bit deceptive
zorro is get this in hawkeye's island
nami is on a sky island that has
advanced weather technology
frankie finds himself on the island of
one doctor vegapunk who i think is the
one responsible for the kuma clones i'm
not sure
brooke is captured by four elbowed
freaks and
robin somewhat auspiciously finds
herself in the company of those that
want to bring her to dragon
as a friend at this point we still have
no idea
as to what luffy has done and as the
story continues we get a host of short
scenes
duvall has been keeping the thousand
sunny safe princess vivi her father and
crocodile all react to what luffy has
been doing in the newspaper
both garp and sengoku retire making room
for the next generation oukiji and
spoker both react also to what luffy has
done but perhaps the most
interesting we get a small look at kobe
who demonstrated haki power
in this short but illuminating scene we
get information that apparently every
naval personnel from vice admiral and up
all have some form of hacky ability but
once that scene comes to a close
we finally learn what luffy in fact did
to grab the attention
of the world it could have been
advantageous to remain hidden go into
hiding and to pretend to be dead like
the navy already expected him to be
but instead luffy rocks up to navy
headquarters where the war has just
finished taking
place as it's under construction all the
naval personnel are away by the way
because this is the last place they
would expect anyone to be after what's
just happened and in this stroke of
genius he commandeers a ship
sails around the island in a circle
before ringing the bell on the island
16 times apparently the bell he rang is
called the ox bell and to ring it 16
times is to signify thanks for the prior
year
and prayers for the upcoming one it's
only carried out by the navy and for
luffy to be pictured doing it in a
moment of silence it's a gesture to the
rest of the new world
that the new era has begun but what
makes this interesting is when each of
the straw hats see this article
on the paper they all come to the same
conclusion putting a hall to their plans
that they had to regroup
instead focusing all their efforts on
training to become
stronger it's revealed that this entire
stunt of his had one specific purpose
to send a signal to his crew the picture
that was taken of luffy taking a moment
of silence
sees a marking on his arm that reads 3d
2y
with the 3d crossed out the straw hats
had agreed to reconvene on the
archipelago in three days
but with the 3d crossed out it seems the
new plan luffy has instructed
is two years to get stronger what a
ridiculously brilliant way to
communicate a specific message to your
crew to say that i freaked out when i
read through this section
is an understatement of the highest
order and it's perfectly in keeping with
the through line of the story right now
luffy hates to be alone and away from
his friends but he's willing to extend
the waiting period if it means that they
are going to be safe together once again
someday and with the crew having decided
what their respective training and
preparation should be
luffy follows rayleigh into the forest
where he begins training
as the old pirate begins explaining to
luffy about the power that dwells within
him providing
super interesting exposition that adds
context to what already surrounds ace's
death and what luffy needs to do in
order to master the now known to us
three different types of haki words
cannot express how utterly giddy and
enthralled i am by what i've just read
this is without a doubt the greatest
story i've ever read
in my entire life and i can't imagine
anything coming close in my immediate
future there's an absolute reason
why this series why this story is so
infectiously popular it's got more heart
than most stories out there and has so
much more ambition in its telling than
i've ever been exposed to
the narrative and poetic symmetry in
this story and this very chapter
serves to me as a perfect example of why
planning your story
offers so much in terms of payoff and
emotional significance
it's why i've never stopped loving
stories they are the only place where
magic
actually exists where good triumphs over
evil and where we can all escape
to whenever our daily lives become
overwhelming you can take a small child
full of dreams and through his eyes take
us on an adventure the likes of which
can uplift us
and fill us with satisfaction and so
despite my eyes full of tears despite my
excitement and sense of loss here
i couldn't help but smile as i watched
otis so the very last stitch
in the masterpiece of a tapestry he's
woven over the course of what was then
13 years of work this is an incredible
and special moment in what i've come to
understand as an incredibly special
story
at the end of my second video covering
this series i confess that one piece
could very well be something i can
appreciate but never fully love as much
as those that grew up with it
and while i can't compare my enjoyment
to anyone else's
this series has on a fundamental level
changed how i view storytelling and has
seriously helped me through some really
tough patches over the last three months
i'll be taking my short break now so in
case youtube forgets about me
if you all do want to see more from me
maybe subscribe and hit that
notification bell in case youtube
doesn't show my videos in the future
when i return
but this most definitely isn't a goodbye
it's a see you later
so until we meet again guys i've been
totally not mark
i'll see you when i see you and thank
you so much for taking the time out of
your days to share it with me
[Music]
you